James Comer chairman of the house
oversight committee Congressman what
does this mean what can you tell us well
I can tell you that on the wire that
Hunter Biden received from the Chinese
National
the beneficiary address listed was Joe
Biden's home address at a time where I'm
pretty certain Hunter Biden was not
living in the home of Joe Biden but if
you if you go back even further than
that this Jonathan Lee who wired the 260
thousand dollars from China to Hunter
Biden's personal account
he is part of the the Chinese Communist
Party he is is a huge business person in
China with the chinese-backed entity
that funds investments in the United
States so what the the one issue in
Congress that Democrats and Republicans
agree on is we don't want China taking
over Industries important to our
national security we won't trying to buy
in Farmland this is the guy that does
that Jonathan Lee is the person who
represents China and if you research it
Joe Biden met with Jonathan Lee he wrote
a letter of recommendation for his child
to get into college in the United States
there is a relationship that was
developed between Joe Biden and Jonathan
Lee when he was vice president and now
we have evidence that Jonathan Lee who
Joe Biden said his son never took any
money from said his son never took any
money from China Joe Hunter Biden's
lawyer said that Hunter never received
any money from this guy we have evidence
that he received over a quarter of a
million dollars and the address listed
on the wire was Joe Biden's personal
residence
oh Congressman I was reading something
on um I think it was on X on formerly
known as Twitter people were saying well
but this happened before Joe was
president before he became president in
January 2020. why does that matter
it doesn't matter and it it happened
while Joe Biden was a candidate for
president he was already running for
president of the United States and this
wire from China who's our biggest enemy
that's the one thing in this in this
Hall where I where I'm currently being
interviewed there's massive disagreement
on funding levels for the government I
don't think that's any secret one thing
that we all agree on is China's a threat
to the United States and here we have
more evidence of the Biden family
receiving millions and millions of
dollars from our adversarial country for
who knows what the bidens never have
said what they did to receive the money
what did Hunter Biden do to receive a
quarter of a million dollars from a
Chinese National affiliated with the
Chinese Communist Party
well maybe it was just more blow art
Congressman that lovely art that I know
you'd love to have hanging in your
living room Congressman good to see you
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else